[Music]
Hercules son of Zeus and champion of
humankind gazed in horror as he realized
he had just committed the most
unspeakable crime imaginable the goddess
Hera who hated Hercules for being born
of her husband's adultery had stricken
him with a temporary curse of madness
and his own fam with casualties
consumed by grief Hercules sought out
the Oracle of Delphi who told him the
path to atonement laid with his cousin
King Eurystheus of Tiryns a favorite of
Harris
Eurystheus hoped to humiliate Hercules
with 10 impossible tasks that pitted him
against invincible monsters and
unfathomable forces instead the King set
the stage for an epic series of
adventures that would come to be known
as the labors of Hercules the first
labor was to slay the Nemean lion who
kidnapped women from devoured warriors
it's golden fur was impervious to arrows
but Hercules cornered the lion in his
dark cave stumbling with a club and
strangle him with his bare hands he
found no tool sharp enough to skin the
Beast until the goddess Athena suggested
using one of its own laws
Hercules returned to Tiryns
wearing the Lions hide frightening King
Eurystheus so much that he hid in a wine
jar from then on Hercules was ordered to
present his trophies at a safe distance
the second target was the Lanyon Hydra a
giant serpent with many heads
perkins fought fiercely but everytime he
cut one head off two more blew in its
place the battle was hopeless until his
nephew yola's fought to cauterize the
necks with fire keeping the heads from
regrowing the dead serpents remains
became the hydra constellation instead
of slaying a beast
Hercules next had to catch one alive
thus Aronian hind was a female deer so
fast it could outrun an arrow
Hercules tracked it for a year finally
trapping it in the northern land of
hyperborea the animal turned out to be
sacred to artemis goddess of the hunt
and Hercules swore to return it when you
riskiest saw the hind he demanded to
keep it instead but as soon as Hercules
let go the animal ran to its mistress
thus Hercules completed his task without
breaking his promise the fourth mission
was to capture the erymanthian boar
which had ravaged many fields advised by
the wise scent or car on Hercules
trapped him by chasing it into thick
snow for the fifth task there were no
animals just their leftovers the stables
where king or GEOSS kept his hundreds of
divine cattle had not been maintained in
ages
Hercules promised to clean them in one
day if he could keep one tenth of their
livestock or Jesus expected the hero to
fail instead Hercules dug massive
trenches re-routing to nearby rivers to
flow through the stables until they were
spotless next came three more beastly
foes each requiring a clever strategy to
defeat
the carnivorous Stymphalian Birds nested
in an impenetrable swamp that Hercules
used a famous special rattle to frighten
them into the air at which point is
shopping doubt no mortal can stand
before the Cretan Bulls mad rampage but
a chokehold and behind the butchery and
the Mad King Diomedes who had trained
his horses to devour his guests got a
taste of his own medicine when Hercules
wrestled him into his own stables the
ensuing feast calmed the beasts enough
for Hercules to bind their mouths but
the ninth labor involves someone more
dangerous than any beast Hippolyta queen
of the Amazons Hercules was to retrieve
four belt given to her by her father
Ares the God of War he sailed to the
Amazon land of her mascara prepared for
battle but the Queen was so impressed
with the hero and his exploits that she
gave the belt willingly for his tenth
labor Hercules had to steal a herd of
magical red cattle from cheerio a giant
with three heads and three bodies on his
way Hercules was so annoyed by the
Libyan desert heat that he shot an arrow
at the Sun the Sun God Helios had marred
the hero strength and lent his chariot
for the journey to the island of arisia
there Hercules fought off durians
herdsmen and his two-headed dog before
killing the giant himself that should
have been the end but Eurystheus
announced that two labors hadn't counted
the Hydra because yonis had helped her
keys killer
and the stables because he'd accepted
payment and so the hero set about is
11th 12th obtaining golden apples from
the garden of the Hesperides nibs
Hercules began by catching the old man
of the sea and holding the
shape-shifting water God until he
revealed the gardens location once there
the hero found the Titan Atlas holding
up the heavens Hercules offered to take
his place
if Atlas would retrieve the apples Atlas
eagerly complied but Hercules then
tricked him into trading places again
escaping with apples in hand the 12th
and final task was to bring back
Cerberus the three-headed hound guarding
the underworld helped by Hermes and
Athena
Hercules descended the met Hades himself
the Lord of the Dead allowed Hercules to
take four beasts if he could do it
without weapons which he achieved by
grabbing all three of his hens at once
when he presented the Hound to a
horrified Eurystheus the king finally
declared the hero's service complete
after twelve years of toil Hercules had
redeemed the tragic deaths of his family
and earned a place in the divine
pantheon but his victory held an even
deeper importance in overcoming the
chaotic and monstrous forces of the
world the hero swept away what remained
of the Titans primordial order reshaping
it into one where humanity can thrive
through his labors Hercules tamed the
world's madness by atone
[Music]
of course the Titans weren't all bad
meet prometheus creator of mortals
traitor to the gods you can also explore
other ancient myths with this playlist